when nine people were killed at a church
in Charleston South Carolina many of you
commented that had the shooter been
black the police would have killed him
and had he been a Muslim
the media would have labeled him a
terrorist we've already told you why we
don't call anyone a terrorist it's our
policy not to use the terms terrorists
or terrorism to label a person group or
action but we've been called out for
calling the events a shooting and not a
massacre and many of you had a problem
with us calling Dylan roof an alleged or
suspected killer Muslim Texan said on
Facebook notice how he is a suspected
gunman any other race and he'd be a dead
terrorist
and Evan Phoenix said this was not
merely a shooting it was a massacre so
let's start with roof himself he was
caught on camera going into the church
and he hasn't protested his innocence
there's also a manifesto that's believed
to been published by him that makes it
clear that he was planning something
like this attack it seems pretty obvious
that he's guilty right so why do we
still call him a suspect or the alleged
killer we have to assume that someone's
innocent until they are proven guilty
and that is a law in many countries
around the world even if there's a
confession we prefer to be careful
especially when the details are still
emerging this is a journalistic standard
that we will always follow especially
for a story this important as for why we
didn't call the Traulsen attack a
massacre it's a bit more simple our
definition for that word is when ten or
more people are killed indiscriminately
that number might seem like a random
choice but we try to apply our standards
consistently at the end of the day
accuracy is the most important thing we
refer to the events as a shooting
mention how many people were killed and
described what we knew about the
suspects motivation as with all our
coverage we choose our words carefully
report the facts and let you form your
own opinion
a white guy who flies a plane into a
government building was it terror or
just anger and some people love to
overuse it now mr. Obama